there are conflicting reports tonight on
whether President Trump is a target in
the various investigations roiling
Washington from the mullah
Russia probe to the Michael Cohen raids
meantime the Justice Department's
inspector general referred its findings
on former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe to federal prosecutors for
possible criminal charges ed Henry is at
the White House with all the
developments ed what's going great to
see you this could be a big deal because
what we're learning today is that the
Deputy Attorney General in an oval
office meeting last week told President
Trump he is not a criminal target in
either the Michael cone investigation or
the special counsel in probe involving
Robert Mahler of course Bloomberg kicked
all this off by reporting that during
this meeting
Rosen Stein basically said the
president's a subject of the Muller
probe meaning his conduct is under
investigation but there's not enough
evidence to charge him Rosenstein was
repeating this for the first time since
Cohn's office and home had been raided
in Fox News is specifically hearing
Rosenstein also told the president he's
not a target of that Cohan investigation
in New York either but Muller it's
important note has not ruled out making
the president a target at a later date
based on evidence that could emerge the
same could happen in the Cohn
investigation which explains why tonight
the president has now added to his legal
team you see him that Rudy Giuliani the
former New York City Mayor former
federal prosecutor he's been sharply
critical of the FBI for going light on
Hillary Clinton but attacking the
president FBI officials like Andrew
McCabe the former number two who was
fired for leaking and now the Inspector
General at the Justice Department has
sent a criminal referral to the US
Attorney here in Washington saying that
McCabe tried to cover all that up by
lying to the FBI's own investigators
McCabe says tonight he believes he'll be
vindicated but it's worth noting that
former Justice Department officials are
telling us that the fact that the
Inspector General who's nonpartisan at
the Justice Department sent this out
this criminal referral it carries a lot
of weight and that's why the president
tweeted a few moments ago that maybe
James Comey
and Andrew McCabe are getting a dose of
their own medicine mark yeah that's
that's pretty amazing news ed thanks for
that Chris Chris wrecker is the
executive assistant was the executive
assistant director of the FBI he's not
one of those who's under criminal
referral and tom Fitton is the president
of judicial watch Tom this is pretty
amazing isn't it we basically got a
situation where the director of the FBI
would be the principal witness in the
criminal prosecution of the deputy
director and possibly vice versa in
commis case it's bizarre times it is and
remember he's the number two at the FBI
or at least was number two was the
senior official charged with
investigating Hillary Clinton over the
email manner and targeting president
Trump as far as I'm concerned his
conduct it's been alleged by the
Inspector General now he's facing
potential prosecution has tainted both
investigations and remember Andrew
McCabe ironically is the FBI official
who reportedly set up the ambush
interview of those agents with general
Flynn and general Flynn was later
charged with lying and admitted to lying
to those agents now mr. McCabe is now
charged could be charged with lying at
least three times under oath to FBI
officials investigate him it's an
extraordinary development and it doesn't
honor well obviously for mr. McCabe mr.
Comey or frankly mr. Muller who took who
hand who was handed this investigation
by McCabe and his team Chris you wrote
today that you're pretty embarrassed
about the state of your old agency and
what it's come to
I mean this is this is the the FBI is
now the issue
nobody cares about Russia that's all
gone away it's actually the conduct of
the highest figures in the FBI that is
now the issue in this story well mark
let me let me just say it's not the FBI
this is what my op-ed was about it was
about not equating the FBI the good men
and women of the FBI with Comey and
McCabe's Croc pay
a very small group that was an
aberration remember combing was only
director for a very short time I mean so
I hate to have the entire FBI painted
with that broad brush when we know that
this small inner circle simply made up
their own rules and did things their own
way and broke the rules some very
well-established rules well just do it
just to go to that we all know that it's
a crime to lie to the FBI and Michael
Flynn supposedly did that and he could
he would have been looking at a several
years in jail if they decided to go and
prosecute for that now
mccabe did it three times as often as
michael Flynn do you think there's any
serious chance he'll be going to jail I
think that the referral by the inspector
general is a very serious thing I mean
it's it's ironic that the potential
charge would be 18 USC at that USC u.s.
code a thousand and one which is lying
to the FBI and that's what Flynn and
Papadopoulos and others have been
charged with so I think it's ironic that
he's facing those very same charges
times three let's let's go on to to
McCabe's old boss Jim Comey who's
managed to make enemies on all sides
which is boding poorly for his book tour
this was the scene outside in New York
City Barnes and Noble where there were
both Pro and anti Trump supporters
United on nothing except how much they
detest Comey antipathy to James Comey is
healing this divided nation what's your
what's your reaction to that Tom you
know the veils been listed the veil has
been lifted James Comey is an anti-trump
activists he might as well be running
the DNC given his hatred for President
Trump and his is deference to Hillary
Clinton you know he illegally leaked in
my view that document about his alleged
conversation with President Trump that I
really don't even think happened the way
he said in order to get a special
counsel appointed so you know breaking
the rules to get a special counsel to
target president Trump that's that's mr.
twister Combes legacy and
and Andrew McCabe is his legacy Peter
struck is his legacy
Lisa Paige is his legacy this is the
culture of corruption that James call me
quickly set up when he was appointed by
Barack Obama to run and a leadership
position ruin the FBI a short time he
was there let me ask Chris a question
about that Chris because you've been
very strong and on this idea that
basically here we have it like in County
Court terms the the policeman usurping
the role of the county attorney when he
absolved Hillary Clinton from any
prosecutable wrongdoing he's not the
prosecutor he's the investigator
why didn't President Obama actually fire
him as FBI director for that well that's
a good question I mean you know this
system is set up to have a filter
between the investigators and a
prosecution or a prosecutor decision and
that's a very sound system and that
keeps the FBI out of politics in this
case he thrusted him directly into
politics sort of a thumbs on the scale
investigation a non investigation with
Clinton and then a pretty push the
envelope investigation on the president
I I'm in favor of an all-out
investigation if you're gonna
investigate and it's fully predicated go
go at it in this case they did not and I
think that fit in with the whole agenda
there Lynch clearly the Attorney General
clearly was in the camp for Clinton was
running some interference for her and
that's what the director former director
Comey cited as the reason he bypassed
her but I can't you know you can't you
can't do that you can't do that
differently just for her sandal this is
a system that has of rules and he should
have followed the rules no no that's
that's a good point equality before the
law
I have dim memories of that